I was doing some IMDb stocking and I
noticed that your first credit is on one
of my favorite films of all time
short-term 12 you are an additional set
production assistant is it just one big
old coincidence that you wound up
crossing paths with Bri later on truly
like could be entanglement unclear I
when I was interning for Marvel Studios
back in I think
2012 um I met a producer and then
interned on short-term 12 and I did
lockups and took out the garbage and saw
Bri from afar and it's synchronicity
it's really cool look at you now also I
feel like that movie in particular is
just one big old good luck charm cuz
look at how many people were affiliated
with that movie that are just like
making Next Level stuff now an
incredible movie and so character-driven
and so well written um good character
work is at the heart of anything that's
great is so true so true all right I
want to recap some of your Marvel
Journey for our viewers because just
seems to me like you keep going up and
up and up so manager of production and
development on Guardians 2 production
and development executive on Captain
Marvel co-executive producer and
supervising producer on W Division and
now full-blown EP on the Marvels what
does it mean to you to be an executive
producer on this film and what's what's
the next goal what's the next step oh my
goodness uh it's a total dream come true
I in high school had Marvel and Stanley
on my vision board I love these
characters whenever I was interning and
making my way through the industry
whenever anyone asked where I wanted to
end up it was always Marvel um and
Captain
Marvel was incredible to work on um I
love these characters so much um I don't
I mean there's nowhere to
go beyond this I I mean it's really
truly the dream I'm just so lucky to be
able to work with the characters in this
universe just curious what is your
vision board look like now oh my gosh
that's a great qu it's just posters just
a lot of posters posters around the
office I I grew up a big uh Buffy fan I
love killbill I love fromy Michelle's
High School reunion um just a cluster of
okay favorite movies all the right
titles there I like it I'm soad I like
it all right I want to refer to
something that you said in our press
note you said that this movie Paints the
biggest picture of the cosmic Marvel
universe that we have seen yet to put
that into perspective for our viewers
can you maybe pinpoint something that's
been done in a past MCU Cosmic movie
that you all take to the next level here
I worked on Guardians of the Galaxy
Volume 2 um of course space and the
scope of space is
so so huge in those films what we really
wanted to do in this film was catch up
with the cosmic Avenger Captain Marvel
and of course it's been theorized what
she might be up to and we really do get
to catch up with her in this film and
come to understand where she's been who
she's connected with um and of course
she's incredibly powerful but the only
thing perhaps more powerful than Captain
Marvel is the scope and power of the
universe itself and that's actually what
she's up against in this film which is
why it's so important that she has the
other two marvels with her because she
can't be expected to shoulder the burden
of the universe all on her own and
together a team is more than the sum of
their parts I love that I'm excited to
dig into that more to get into maybe
some specific scenes or locations you
name it of everything you needed to do
in this movie going into production
which did you think would be the most
challenging of the bunch but then
ultimately was that indeed the most
challenging or did something else Catch
You by surprise oh my gosh what a great
question I think aladana musical planet
um so excited to see that was perhaps
the most daunting and it took months and
months of choreography and planning and
designing I mean the costumes alone my
gosh um Lindsay P costume designer just
crushed it um there was so much practice
and time poured into that sequence and
then of course when filming it was just
a blast the whole crew was dancing
everyone came and just did an incredible
job there's a lot of things that I'm
really looking forward to in this film
that might be close to the top of the
list another quote I wanted to reference
from our notes you had called Nia an
incred rly visual Dynamic Storyteller
and put an emphasis on how good she was
at action can you maybe pinpoint
something in the script that she just
took to the next level with a really
inventive idea as an action director
that you know really surprised you and
made you say something like that the
first big sequence in which all of the
Marvels find themselves entangled um
where they are all apart and find their
way together as a team was incred
incredibly difficult incredibly
difficult to write incredibly difficult
to storyboard Nia had a huge hand and
led the charge on all of that um there
was so much to track and the experience
as a viewer is just an all-around good
time it's smooth it's action-packed it's
fast and I think audiences will really
love being along for the journey even
cut up in trailers it's already playing
well so I got high hopes here's a a big
question but maybe an important one what
were the conversations between like you
and Nia and the whole team like in terms
of making sure that this movie continued
important story threads that Marvel has
set up thus far but also that it stood
on its own two feet and was still
accessible for someone who isn't caught
up on everything or maybe is using the
Marvels as an on-ramp for sure I think
what's great about this movie is if you
are a huge fan of the comics if you're a
huge fan of the MCU if you've seen the
incredible Miss Marvel show if you've
seen W Division if you saw the first
captain Marvel movie there's so much to
follow so many threads to pick up with
this film uh that really pay off but at
the end of the day if you're less
familiar with the storytelling thus far
this is about three people really
meeting for the first time and coming
together just like any movie you meet
new characters um and get to know them
and get caught up to speed um and this
movie does it with extreme dynamism um
so I'm excited for people to enjoy
whether they're huge fans um or new fans
I love it I'll end with this one here so
we are now conditioned in the MCU to
assume that any specific characters
movies is going to wind up being a
Trilogy so is that the case here were
you guys thinking of the Marvels as the
second chapter of Captain Marvel's
Trilogy story this certainly is the
second chapter in the Captain Marvel
story um this team up has long been in
the works um it was a it was a decision
to make Monica the age that she was in
the first Captain Marvel movie because
we knew that we wanted Carol and Monica
to share the big screen together and of
course when Miss Marvel came into the
mix it's a no-brainer she's the perfect
lens um through which we can examine
Carol as a character um
so I mean it's it's it's really amazing
to bring them all together on screen um
and as for additional installments um uh
I I can neither confirm nor deny
anything because Marvel security is
always watching but I I as a fan hope to
see more you have been trained well but
this is what happens when you make
things we want more of we can't help it
congratulations thank you so
much